i was gonna i was gonna say would you
here's a question would you sacrifice
happiness for fulfillment
yeah
would you because i think happened like
you said happiness can go up and down
yeah like it's an emotion right it comes
it's not happiness isn't a
permanent state that you can be in but
you can be content and fulfilled what
you have
but we just sacrifice happiness for
fulfillment
then it depends like for me
happiness
is probably
oh no to be fair happiness isn't
dependent on fulfillment but i'm always
over the i was like we could die
tomorrow and if you're not happy and if
you're not like content if you're not if
you're not a whole
individual
then anything else that you like put
yourself into like
i don't know it's a really tough that's
it nothing is ever black that's it going
back that nothing is black and white
right or wrong better or worse
um
nothing's right or wrong but like it's
that gray area of like in some
situations i'd probably be like
i'll sacrifice happiness for like even
when you study or you you do a job if
you do a job you're not interesting i
think if you ask men the same question
most of them would say yes i think women
care a lot more about being happy and
men care a lot more about being
fulfilled well that's that's like
because i think i think it's not about
like you especially if you have a family
it's not about you anymore like doesn't
she leave does she leave a husband and
kids and eat pray love
uh she needs a husband
a husband a job yeah like i don't know i
think that's that's a bit selfish you're
leaving a commitment you made for what
to go like go to india but to be selfish
means that we're prioritizing what
everyone else wants compared to what we
want yeah but sometimes what you want
isn't right like emotions come and go
people leave that's it right and wrong
very subjective there's it's all about
that gray area walking the middle path
right and wrong to one person so that's
it genocide and racism to one person is
right
like
things to one person are correct and you
could argue to your blue in the face and
be like that's not correct and they
literally will be like like that's it
hitler hitler literally what is she it's
not even right correct i think there's
consequences and i i i'd really like to
circle back with that lady
she made a book she made a lot of money
it might have worked out yeah yeah no
she made banks yeah so you know what i
mean maybe she did but i don't think the
average woman that makes that decision
it's going to end up well for her no no
no no and that's why you've got to be
cognizant of differences and privileges
and
circumstances and things like that so
yeah the average woman could not be like
i'm not happy in my job or my marriage
or being a mum yeah because then you're
like well [ __ ]
finances your your marriage your family
like your kids and the average woman
could not do that
um but it doesn't mean that she
shouldn't want to or she like it's just
like ah but then you get stuck
being like are you living for yourself
or are you living for others are you
living for expectations i think it's
okay
i think it's okay to live for others and
i'll give you an example okay yeah i
live a lot for my dad's approval like a
lot i care a lot what my dad thinks like
a lot and i do a lot of things not
because i want to but because he wants
me to and i don't mean like like i would
i'm doing this clearly because i love
this yeah he doesn't care about social
media but just in terms of like like my
last boyfriend my dad didn't like and
that really bothered me it bothered me a
lot because i love my dad and i think
like there's some things it's okay
it's almost a good thing to like put you
know values and like your commitments
and like your word above what makes you
happy at the time yeah i i was gonna say
i think the difference between people
today and people back in the day is that
we back in the day people all about
community yeah it was all about doing
what's best for the community it was all
about doing what's best for your family
whereas now
i think
i think back then we didn't have enough
individualism
that people were sacrificing a lot of
their happiness for their community but
now we've gone the other way
where there's so much individualism now
yeah that people are no longer
contributing or even care about their
local community or their family and
their nuclear family which is why people
leave
et cetera et cetera so i i agree and
you know i'm my family nigerian and in
our culture like once you have kids it's
about them you do what's best for them
so
if you but you staying with your partner
is what's best for the kids and you can
make that work that's what you do until
they leave then you split up or whatever
i actually i always say people always
ask me if i'd stay with the cheater and
i always say no unless
there were kids
interesting why do you say that because
if they're kids it's not about me
how about you if it i would um i mean
i've i've stayed with jesus i've stayed
producers and i know a lot of that is
actually based upon my self-worth and
being like you know xyz and i'd love to
say no i know i deserve better and no no
but yeah if there's kids it's a whole
different ballpark and if you're it
depends on how selfish yourself because
being selfish isn't a bad thing because
if you're like well i'm living for
others then when do you live for you
because
and it oh it really depends on like so a
lot of people love honor and pride so
you don't think being selfish is a bad
thing so no no so you say you live for
your dad's approval my dad's a piece of
[ __ ] yeah that's a piece of [ __ ] my
family
we are not close at all my mom literally
had been like me
and so i'm like if i'm not living for me
and enjoying my life i could be dead
tomorrow and if i knew that i lived for
everyone else i'm living for their
approval or my well-being
and my quality of life is dependent upon
how they feel towards me yeah and if
that's it it's not black and white it's
very much like
the people i love
know that i love them the people i love
i'm i'm very much a i want you to feel
loved i want you but then i'm like
i've done a lot of therapy and so
they're like hey amy you can only feel
good about yourself when you think
others feel good about you and they're
like that's really
so your self-worth is dependent upon the
approval of others i think that's normal
well if everyone hates you there's
probably a reason well
as far as i'm aware no one has ever
hated me but i've been so i stayed with
the cheetah because yeah i've stayed
with many teachers
and i
i've been in a relationship that was
the most toxic thing that i've ever
imagined that everyone in my life is
like we don't he still talks to me and i
still haven't we broke up three
four years ago we still have an open
communication path because i can't block
people because i'm like i feel really
bad if i block them even if they're
toxic for me and they're worse i can't
block them
i can't i can't do it i can't do it and
everyone is like amy
like are you are you confused this
person was awful to you disrespected you
and you still feel the need to be good
for them good for their approval
and i'm just like
ah because it makes you feel like a bad
person word block people